now eurozone finance ministers have
finally approved a four-month extension
to Greece's bailout agreement the deal
has been well received by the markets
with stocks in both New York and London
closing at record highs or the
journalists at Philip and Alex joins me
now live from Athens very good if you
join me on Sky world news what are
ordering ordinary Greeks make of this
house Tsaritsa delivered on all of its
election pledges well there's a lot of a
relief here but it's certainly been a
baptism of fire for Alexis tsipras
series like government there any been in
power for it was barely a month now
they've been caught between a rock and a
hard place trying to negotiate with the
europeans and their international
creditors on one hand and on the other
hand trying to keep their pre election
promises to end up end or stereo tea and
tear up the bailout agreement but
reality was with the banks running low
on cash as Greek got nervous and been
withdrawing cash from their bank
accounts thought that more than 20
billion euros is left Greek bank
deposits in the last couple of months
they were desperate to do a deal and
keep funding going so yeah they've gone
back on a lot of their promises but I
think they had very little choice
especially with the Germans playing
hardball and insisting that they stick
to previous agreements but the fact that
they've got this for months extension is
effectively a lifeline for the banks
because they'd like to get continued
funding from the European Central Bank
and it's expected that the ECB will in
that in the coming days turn around and
accept Greek bonds as collateral again
which will give breathing space the
Greek banks but at the same time they've
kept some of their promises in that at
least they have their own destiny in the
hand they get to choose which reforms
they make and the Greek government here
is claiming that they don't have
recessionary measures because remember
the Greek economy has shrunk by
something like twenty five percent in
the last five years of very tough
austerity and they're trying to take
social measures as well with
unemployment to twenty five percent
youth unemployment a 50-percent poverty
levels approaching what's thought to be
nearly forty percent so very difficult
because they're also trying to keep
their their MPs happy and we've also had
a little bit of dissent from some senior
leftist MPs within syriza but the
reality is I think people are relieved
and we saw that with the markets as well
yes as you said the athens stock
exchange gainey
ten percent yesterday on news that the
Eurogroup had given the green light for
this four-month extension yeah well we
know it's a lifeline for the banks but
what about ordinary Greeks as well can
you give us any concrete examples of
what impact it will have on their life
well a huge relief that the banks will
stay but we'll carry on operating
normally because there were concerns
with funds running low but the Greeks
might have been forced to impose capital
controls something similar to what we
saw in Cyprus a couple of years ago so
there's relief that the banking sector
is safe certainly for the time being a
bit of disappointment that another
government has been voted in with making
lots of promises before the elections
and has had to renege on some of them at
the same time I think people are being
realistic and saying there was no other
way to do anything else for the time
being there will be some some scope for
improvement in that one of the details
that sort of be left a little bit vague
is this primary surplus everybody's
talking about where in the past the
previous agreement had said that Greece
had to keep a primary surface of three
percent this year and four and a half
percent next year now the wording in the
agreement has been left vague with the
Greeks hope hoping that they'll be given
leeway to have a smaller primary surplus
and therefore spend some that money on
social funding creating some new jobs
helping the poor they're already talking
about free electricity and free food for
the very hard hit that people who can't
afford to feed themselves going to the
soup kitchens all the people who kind of
want to pay for their electricity but a
lot of the other measures are going to
be difficult for now and the focus has
certainly been on things like cracking
down on corruption and tax evasion now
these are things that Greece's
international creditors are very keen on
but the reality is with these sort of
problems which are endemic and have been
problems for decades in Greece's it
takes time to actually enforce these
measures and it takes even longer to get
money coming through so you can actually
spend it on social spending all the sort
of things that soon as I promise to do
like reinstating filling we have to
leave it there Philip pangalos many
thanks for your time